forget everything you thought you knew
about animals in America and hang out
with hundreds of elves wreaking havoc in
a Colorado Town they're all over the
place then grab a life jacket as the
world's largest mammal swims Inland for
the summer it's a whale of
paloa get pumped up with wild turkeys
ready to take a bite out of the Big
Apple don't try to make friends with
them and track a stealthy feline across
a South Carolina Paradise they're all
over this
island welcome to the Field Guide to the
most incredible wildlife in America this
is the United States of
animals and this is a Rocky Mountain
rut and when Bulls compete for babes
there's bound to be a fight but the
folks of esd's Park Colorado don't mind
they even throw a
party woohoo
and you've got an open invitation to
elkfest held every October in es Park
Colorado elk fist began here 17 years
ago people come from around the world to
see them now we estimate there probably
between 10 and 15,000 people that's
because if you want to watch elk running
rough shot over an entire town est's
park is one of the best places in the
country to do it sometimes huge long
lines of traffic build up in spots are
police department they don't call it a
traffic jam they say there's an elk Jam
rut mating love whatever you call it
you'll have a front row seat to this
spectacle in esd's park it's really fun
to watch their behavior during the rut
because there's nothing like it in the
world while you can spot elk all over
town folks around here will tell you
they really like hanging out on the
links they seem to congregate on the
golf course because it's a wide open
spans and they just can't beat the lush
green
grass Bulls also like to Bugle on flat
Open Spaces where sound travels farther
it's Nature's bullhorn sending their
mating calls echoing from
Miles the Bulls bugle during the rut
it's kind of how they claim their ground
and claim their ladies you actually
can't believe that sound comes out of
such a huge animal that you can here in
the entire Valley and after the ladies
come running the stud bll rounds them up
keeping a watchful eye on his herum of
up to 20 cows the dominant male bull
really holds control over his cows when
they're ready to mate he'll mate with
them until then he's got a guard against
Young Bucks trying to Horn in on his
brood there's a lot of younger bulls
that are interested in taking some of
the cows away to build their own Herm
and just like elbowing your way through
elkfest all this fighting and Herm
building is hard
work adult Bulls show up in est's park
for battle weighing up to 1,000 lb and
reaching up to 9 ft at the tip of their
antlers but during the 24/7 rut there's
just no time for a fella to eat Bulls
can lose up to 20% of their body weight
that's 2 200
lb but the chance to mate is worth it in
fact these bulls will do anything to
attract
females and we mean
anything part of the meting ritual for
the bull go is to tear up the grass dig
their antlers in and uh urinate all over
the mud yeah then lay down and wallow it
they're pretty proud of
that that urine creates a distinct smell
that drives the ladies wild it's like
the original Old Spice elk
style the incredible Aroma May lure them
in but it's the antlers that seal the
deal weighing 40 lb and reaching widths
of up to 4 ft that's like carrying
around a three-year-old on your
forehead and in this neck of the woods
there's one legendary bull that no Young
Buck has
surpassed
yet meet Samson a Goliath who weighed in
at 1,000 lb and stood 8 ft tall from
head to hoof Estus Park pretty much
adopted him as our mascot they even
immortalized him with a bronze
statue Samson died in 1995
but his descendants still roam est's
Park all vying for a top spot in the
herd each year we see some pretty mature
bulls that rival Samson in size but at
this year's hefest there's one bull
everyone wants to
see a magnificent stud named Magnus I
love that bull I've been chasing him for
2 days trying to catch up to him in his
sexual prime surging testosterone has
helped him grow an impressive rack he is
just Regal and I think he's going to be
the successor to Samson and for Magnus
to succeed he'll have to put those
antlers to the
test when pretty good siiz Bull and the
herd bull decide hey we're going to
really go at it and lock horns it'll be
the stronger bull that dominates the
girls ultimately it may end up being a
fight to the death one of them has to
back down or be injured or be killed
keep that in mind while watching these
mammoths rut because to a bull elk
pumped on testosterone anything that
moves can be a Target so please consider
this Pro tip a warning before an elk
charges they kind of start walking
towards you very slowly and then they
put their head down like that and nod
their antlers towards you you need to
back off and if you hear a gut wrenching
Bellow from
behind Run for the Hills
like our
cameraman it's that bugle again a stud
Bull's Anthem a lot of people have never
heard such a sound and no other animal
in the wild can duplicate
it except for humans that is welcome to
the most popular event at est's elf
Fest the bugling contest we have kids
two years old up to professionals that
come out and try to bugle like an elk
and if you're good enough to fool a stud
you'll
win hands
down the bug sounds so much like a real
bull that big huge Bulls come running
down into the
park it's really fun so if you think you
got what it takes to bugle like a sex
crave bull get yourself down to es
Colorado PEAK rut is mid September
through mid October but time your visit
for the first weekend of October and
you'll get to enjoy elkfest
too if you're lucky you'll spot Magnus
and his mighty herum walking around town
or you could take in around of golf or
maybe
not we're leaving the Colorado mountains
and dropping into the Pacific Ocean just
off Dana Point
California to ride along with a monster
of the deep who's surfacing right
offshore the blue
whale these endangered behemoths used to
blow right past California on their
migration South 10 years ago if I saw
one blue well out here I would be on a
national news program because it was so
rare but now these gentle Giants are
camped just miles off the Golden Coast
last year we had nearly a thousand
sightings it's unbelievable is a once in
a-lifetime chance to spot a blue whale
yourself I did not know that they were
so close to Shore that you could see
them so this summer you got to get to
Dana Point California the best place to
catch these goliaths up close and
personal it's hard to beat how big they
are biggest animal that ever
lived growing up to 100 ft long and
weighing close to 200 tons they're
larger than any dinosaur that ever lived
their heart is the size of a Volkswagen
Bug and their tongue it could weigh as
much as an elephant
with such enormous mouths can you guess
what the weight of their daily food
intake
equals is it a one school bus B a
bulldozer C two
cars the answer when United States of
animals
Returns the blue whale the weight of
their daily food intake is massive did
you know that these whales eat up to
8,000 lb pound of krill a day that's the
weight of two
cars it's amazing what they can consume
and even more impressive when you
realize what a Krill
is just think of a tiny pink shrimp now
go smaller a Krill is only 2 in long the
length of a AA battery they can eat up
to 4 tons of krill in one day and lucky
for you Dana Point California is teaming
with them but why there and why
now scientists believe climate changes
in the Pacific Ocean have brought a bevy
of krill to the
Shoreline we think that they just
shifted their feeding
patterns everybody is Happy except for
the
Krill and it's not just blue whales
taking advantage of the smorgus board
there's gray whales pump backs even
orchids it's a whale of paloa a lot of
people think oh the blue whales are here
in California you know I'll go next year
and see them you know what they might
not be here next year so take this Pro
tip straight from the locals plan your
trip to Dana Point
now and to see these Giants up close
just hop on a tour booat when the whales
are migrating south for the winter we
see them here from May through October
typically only 2 or 3 miles offshore
since many of the blue whales have
started returning to these ERS every
summer the crew can pick a few out by
sight our number one well just came
up they've even named their favorites
including a playful female named Delta
it's awesome seeing Delta every year and
this year is even more special Delta has
brought along her newborn calf it's just
an amazing thing here to Sea and there's
no shortage of incredible moments when
surrounded by blue whales they'll swim
over they'll connect with us they'll
connect with other
Dolphins
Dophin bet you never knew that blue
whales can travel with a
posy so here's another Pro tip keep your
eyes peeled for dolphins who might be
hitching a ride what I'm seeing here is
just unbelievable blue whales generate
one colossal swell in their weight
something that clever Dolphins can't
pass up they are catching a ride from
the pressure wave of this whale it's
fantastic but there's trouble on the
horizon that can trigger a wipe out or
much worse there's a whale real close to
that ship I mean seriously close it's
hard to believe there's something bigger
than a 200 ton blue whale cruising the
currents of the Pacific it's a super
tanker some of the country's biggest
chipping Lanes lie just off Dana points
Shoreline so if you think rush hour on
the freeway is bad it can't compared to
this gridlock of giants in the
Pacific unfortunately these Wells don't
always get out of the way when these
ships are coming luckily the Marine
Exchange of Southern California is
working to steer the big Blues out of
Harm's
wayo sped traffic there have been well
sightings in the vicinity of 3336 239
North
11819 029 West please proceed with
precautions thank you and only in SoCal
can you find traffic controllers for
whales when we get reports of whale
concentrations we tell the ships where
they are so they can avoid those
locations hopefully these efforts will
guide ships away from the whales and
into safer Waters now if only someone
can handle the bottleneck on the
highways too but if there's anything
worth braving bumper-to-bumper traffic
for it's the blue whale people should
come and see this this is fantastic but
remember remember if you want to catch
the blues be sure to get to Dana Point
between May and
September do it sooner then later cuz
it's
wonderful from the Golden Sands of
California we're heading east to the big
city burrow of Staten Island New
York where wild turkeys are taking the
City by
storm they're
tough they're
loud and they're
aggressive so in this town they fit
right in turkeys try to exert their
dominance over one another and develop a
pecking order they are
Fighters but as we all know if you can
make it here you can make it anywhere
and that's what these wild turkeys are
counting on my mom's been here since the
1950s and she remembers there always
being some wild turkeys on St Island in
New York States Turkey population is
looking healthy so they're here to stay
whether the locals like it or
not I'm not a fan of birds in general
especially not big wild turkeys my fear
is if one happens to charge I don't know
if I could defend myself understandable
as wild turkeys don't take kindly to
strangers definitely don't try to make
friends with
them but some Staten Islanders do
appreciate their fine feathered
Brethren it is sort of a novelty to be
able to drive and see a flock of 40 or
50 turkeys just hanging out and crossing
the
street and you won't believe how this
nice New York City suburb became home to
the original Gangs of New York who live
fight and love like no breed in town but
don't think you can break the code cuz
these turkeys have their own foul
language can you guess how many sounds
besides gobble gobble a turkey can make
is it a 14
b28 or c 3 5 the answer when United
States of animals
[Music]
returns just how vast is a turkey's
vocabulary with 28 different words to
choose from these birds really can talk
turkey they all associate the gobble
with the wild turkey but they do a whole
lot of other sounds as well they
whine
yel
her and
cackle
and rumor has it this particular posi
clucked their way out of a breeder lot
right into the Wilds of Staten Island
there's been anecdotal stories of people
keeping these turkeys in their backyards
releasing them and then establishing
this population turkeys may have taken
over the streets of Staten Island but
like most City dwellers they spurned
cars in favor of smarter modes of
transportation these big large heavy
birds can actually make short bursts of
flight
and Fly Fast reaching up to 55 mph they
can also run 25 mph leaving most humans
in the dust or snow cuz these birds
scoff at the cold some nights it gets
down to 20 and 30 below and has
virtually no effect on them they'll fly
up to a branch fluff up their body
feathers to trap air and conserve energy
wait did he say
branches yep if you're heading to Staten
Island after dark just look up to see
these birds roosting in the Treetops it
is interesting to come in the evening
when you can see the turkeys beginning
their roosting behaviors where they will
fly up into trees and spend the
night there's just one more thing a man
needs on those cold city nights these
frisky Toms can never pass up a chance
to score with the ladies the goers have
breeding on their mind all year round
but who can blame this guy Keen Street
smarts rugged good looks like the George
Clooney of birds
what's not to love personally speaking I
think they're
magnificent even Benjamin Franklin had a
thing for turkeys preferring the gobler
as our national bird instead of the bald
eagle the head of the gobler is more
naked than that of the hand it's bright
red white and blue very
patriotic a turkey's head neck and snood
change color like a mood ring predicting
the level of excitement at turkey's
feeling at the
moment but this game bird is much more
than just the Island's resident
hothead we've had presidents that have
led turkeys it is a part of our American
history seems like he just can't keep a
good Tom down they're beautiful birds
they're fun to
watch and if you want to see these
gobblers strut their stuff on Staten
Island come between December and March
when Toms and hens band together in one
big flock the Brave the winter but if
you suffer from meleis phobia the fear
of turkeys shoot for spring once mating
season is over that's when hands take to
their nests cutting this foul mob in
half but if you do come see the wild
turkeys have some respect don't feed the
birds we're headed from the concrete
jungle of New York to the Sandy Dunes of
kiaa Island just 21 miles from
Charleston South
Carolina and here it's all about
southern hospitality even for the town's
infamous feline
interloper the Bobcat it's an animal
that people people like people really
get excited when they have encounters
with Bobcats for us it's just been a
perfect mascot here Kian you could
encounter a bobcat at any time anywhere
they're perfectly at home here wait a
feline Predator that's soaking up the
sun in a Seaside Paradise what's wrong
with this
picture actually it's not kio's pristine
beaches that Bobcats love it's the
barrier Island's 10 miles of lush
Maritime vegetation they're going to be
in the densely vegetated Dunes on the
marsh Edge the transition between forest
and tidal Marsh is very dense with a lot
of good cover for them to hide in these
dense pockets of seagrass and shrubs
also line the Island's nature trails
creating a hidden Labyrinth that works
like a bobcat Super Highway Bobcats take
advantage of our Leisure trail system so
they basically serve as travel corridors
for these cats a great habitat for
Bobcats but it's not the habitat alone
that attracts Bobcats to this Southern
Sanctuary kioa Island's 1500 residents
are so dang nice they landscape their
yards to offer the felines even more
room to roam we want to make sure that
every backyard is an extension of our
natural Maritime forest or an extension
of our Dune system that helps to keep
the wildlife here you're not going to
see a white picket fence on Kio Island
it's a true Wild
place I don't have a lum mower I don't
have anything and the efforts of the
locals to make their home a Haven for
Bob Cats is paying off kiaa has about
three wild cats on every square mile of
the island making it one of the best
places in the United States to spot a
bobcat we probably have twice the
density of bobcats you'd find most
places but this doesn't mean they will
be easy to see despite being the most
common wild cat in the country these
stealthy hun are also one of the
toughest to spot they're very good at
what they do and they're a lot better at
avoiding us than we are at finding
them weighing up to 33 lb this feline is
roughly four times the weight of a
domestic house
cat the name comes from their small
bobbed tail that's about 5 to 8 in Long
Fierce Hunters these cats can hunt prey
up to twice their size the stealthy
Bobcat can deliver a death blow with a
pounce covering 10 ft that's long longer
than a small
car and when you're on the hunt to spy a
bobcat there are ways to track this
covert operator the best time to see
them is Dawn and dusk cuz that's when
they're just settling down for the day
or they're just coming out for the night
but our main Pro tip for bird dogging a
bobcat is a cue from the locals there
are definitely other animals that'll let
you know that Bobcats are in the area
crows are huge and letting you know when
there are predators around if you hear
birds squawking they'll certainly scold
Bobcats when they're out walking around
during the
day not much temps of bob cat out of his
den in broad daylight except during
breeding season so head to kiaa in March
and April when these bold Toms will be
on the prowl for
mates but above all if you come to see
kio's Bobcats just relax after all
that's what island life is all about the
most important things to know about
viewing any Wildlife especially
Bobcats is to slow down sit down and
you'll see some amazing
[Music]
moments